Kate Steinle killed back in July of 2015
walking arm-in-arm with her father on a
pier in San Francisco shot and killed by
an illegal immigrant jose garcia Zarate
this man had seven prior felony
convictions for involving narcotics
this was his facing of a sixth
deportation at the time he shot and
killed this innocent woman sanctuary
cities tonight those that support them
they are to blame for the death of Kate
Steinle joining us now are two mothers
whose sons have been killed at the hands
of illegals here with us is Maryanne
Mendoza her son police sergeant Brandon
Mendoza was killed during a head-on
collision with an illegal immigrant who
was recklessly driving on the wrong side
of the road back in 2014 and also with
us is Agnes given her son Ron Doug
DeSilva was shot and killed by an
illegal gang member while he was
standing in a driveway back in 2002
women as a mother I feel for you for the
loss of life a senseless loss of life
and I know this is very difficult we do
appreciate you being here with us
tonight and Maryanne I want to start
with you with your reaction to the
stunning a verdict how do you think
Kate's parents are coping with this
right now I can't imagine the heartbreak
and the failure that they're feeling
that this justice system in the United
States has dealt them and you know these
crimes started our border look at Brian
Terry the Border Patrol agent who was
killed and countless other Border Patrol
agents who are killed it spreads
throughout our country and it's
happening to hundreds of thousands of
Americans this isn't just as awful as it
is this isn't just about Kate Steinle
there are your neighbors and your family
and your friends are being affected by
an illegal alien crime in this country
and we've started as much as the
liberals don't like to hear this we've
started advocates for victims of illegal
alien crime which is avyakta us to bring
awareness to the American people and I'm
challenging Mitch McConnell to bring
Kate's law and no sanctuary for
criminals out
to the Senate floor and get those two
things passed prior to any discussions
about daca because both of those bills
deal with illegal alien felons over
500,000 of them in our country awaiting
deportation this insanity has got to
stop it's really true and I can agree
with you so much you know being a former
prosecutor and working in San Francisco
in the Los Angeles district attorney's
office in California having such a large
population of illegal immigrants that
come in Andreea fendle the time agnus do
you agree with Shawn do you think that
sanctuary cities killed Kate Steinle
absolutely
oh I'm sorry go ahead Agnes yes yes I do
it's a direct result of our inept
government the corrupt government the
Liberals in the state of California that
allowed this to happen
they sent a very clear message yesterday
the governor of California Jerry Brown
the judicial system the mayors and the
Sheriff's Department that they're going
to be protecting the criminals and not
as American citizens it's a disgrace
the problem here that we see Marian is
when you see like you know repeated
deportations like in the case of Zarate
who murdered Kate Steinle coming in and
out back and forth a revolving door and
a system that is broken that allows this
person to come back in and reoffended
kill the that's not the only person and
and this is what the American people
need to understand there's offenders who
are coming over our border 20 and 25
times 18 times coming back over raping
innocent children there's a rape
epidemic going on in South Carolina
there are so many crimes that are
committed by people who are deported and
walk right back over our border and
Americans are kidding themselves that
they don't think that we need a wall and
we need a secure border in our country
it's the only way that it's going to
stop this repeat offense
magnesite why do you think which why
should law-abiding Americans tolerate
any kind of crime from illegal
immigrants and that's that basically
what the president United States is
saying why should we tolerate it why
should the taxpayers why should the
mothers and fathers and sisters and
brothers who have suffered unspeakable
loss
tolerate this type of behavior we
shouldn't American citizens should not
be tolerating this and they ought to be
calling the congressman's and demanding
this nonsense to stop how many lives is
one too many
how many lives more are we going to lose
what message did San Francisco sent to
the rest of the country that you can
come to California you can kill and you
walk free this is insanity this this
needs to stop I was heartbroken and
furious with the system I'm a legal
immigrant myself we follow the law and
for the first time I was disappointed
with my country oh my goodness you can
only imagine right I mean you are both
so brave such wonderful beautiful women
to come here and to share this with the
people out there the real life the
suffering and disappointment that you
have you know in your hearts I can only
imagine when you go to bed at night how
much you must you know miss your boys
Mary Ann and Agnes thank you so much for
being here with us tonight thank you for
having me